c'est la plus grande des quatre îles des
baléares des calanques à couper le
souffle des plages de sable chaud au
milieu de la méditerranée majorque est
une escale paradisiaque où s'invitent 12
millions de touristes chaque année
mais vous allez voir majorque ce n'est
pas uniquement ça on commence notre
week-end par une petite visite
culturelle en plein coeur de palma avec
le palais de l'almudaina c'est notre
incontournable
bonjour julien bienvenue au palais royal
de l'almudaina venez avec moi je vais me
faire visiter
ancienne forteresse mort devenu palais
royal catholique au 14e siècle
l'almudaina témoignent d'un passé
mouvementé
cette tour que l'on appelle à tour de
l'espoir c'est le passage secret que
pouvaient utiliser le gouverneur
musulman de lille pour s'échapper disent
ils pouvaient atteindre facilement le
pas
et ils devaient descendre avec une corde
c'est ça
oui c'était la seule solution parce que
c'était la seule tour construite sans
escalier
aujourd'hui l'almudaina est l'une des
résidences d'été du roi d'espagne
alors maintenant visiter le bureau de sa
majesté le roi
c'est ici que felipe 6e reçoit ses
invités en toute simplicité
tous les recoins de ce château abrite
une histoire ou des légendes
l'une des plus mystérieuses se situe
dans les sous sol de la forteresse
ici se trouvait le laboratoire de
l'alchimiste jacques mistral
et qu'est-ce qu'ils fabriquaient cet
alchimiste français dans son atelier
l'une de ses idées c'est est de
transformer le métal en or
mais leur véritable de l'île et 30 km
plus au nord
ces agrumes sont arrivés il ya 600 ans
dans les cales des bateaux arabe depuis
ses orangeraies de sawyer font la
fortune de la vallée
il faut couper la tige et sans les
feuilles c'est mieux place à simon
racine emprunt à 3 c j'ai essayé la
celle ci
paraît belle alors sans les feuillants
tac
[Musique]
la famille de sebastian à récolte chaque
saison à la main
4500 kg d'orange après c'est plus qu'à
déguster
c'est vraiment délicieux
en contrebas de la vallée dans le port
de sawyer cette relique de 1913
fonctionne toujours à merveille
[Musique]
si tu veux à paris tu visites la tour
eiffel et si tu viens soyhières tu
prends le tramway c'est comme un musée
ambulant
infatigable ce tramway en bois verni ne
dessert qu'une station
les routes majorque in ignore la ligne
droite ici un kilomètre à vol d'oiseau
équivaut à 10 en voiture
notre destination est une merveille
géologiques les grottes du dragon
s'étendent sur un kilomètre et demi à 25
mètres sous terre
leurs pasteurs les bergers amener leurs
brebis ici pour qu'elle se repose et
quand l'une d'entre elles
disparaissaient on disait qu'un dragon
laver manger
pour les visiter un seul moyen se
laisser glisser sur les eaux d'un lac
souterrain
la somme sur le lac martel qui doit son
nom à l'explorateur français qui a
découvert cette partie des grottes
c'est l'un des lacs souterrains les plus
grands d'europe même l'un des plus
grands
ici la température ne varient presque
pas toujours comprise entre 18 et 20
degrés la promesse d'une douce ballade
dans les entrailles de la terre avant de
rejoindre les seniors
au lieu de pèlerinage
sainte-marie de yoox sainte patronne de
lille est une basilique de mandat
et pour moi cette basilique c'est comme
une coupe en or une chose précieuse
qu'il faut prendre soin les gens qui
viennent en ce lieu poussés par leur foi
ou simplement parce qu'ils aiment bien
être au milieu de la nature trouve un
lieu de rencontre
pour accéder aux chambres on peut
traverser la magnifique nef de la
basilique
c'est un tournoi grâce avait stationné
avant on accueillait les pèlerins ici et
aujourd'hui ce sont des chambres comble
n inspirait liens à partir de 20 euros
la nuit
regardez cette merveilleuse
vous dormirez dans ce havre de paix
[Musique]
non vous ne rêvez pas vous êtes bien au
ciel
[Musique]
mais la bienvenue au paradis profitez de
ce moment il est uni
c'est toujours magique quand le ciel est
dégagé on peut voir toutes les villes
voisines la montgolfière mais apporte
une sensation de paix de tranquillité a
l'impression de flotter dans le ciel et
si on ferme les yeux on n'a pas
l'impression d'être dans une
montgolfière
c'est de la pure magie au début on ne
voyait absolument rien et en prenant de
l'altitude on découvre un autre monde
c'est incroyable
notre week-end s'achève ici au dessus
d'une ligne qui semble émerger d'une mer
de nuages comme si elle s'était un peu
envolé avec lui
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]